hello you guys uh welcome to another
video today we are on uh
F-150 and the year for this is uh
22 and we're going to do it with uh fdrs
so this is the new
model so we're just going to go on our
computer and first we're going to
connect internet and all the good stuff
so we connected that we put the internet
and we can see that all those three
things are green um and this point we
can just put the key the car in on
position so we can see that the cluster
is on and now we're just going to go
ahead and do read VIN from
vehicle and after the VIN is here we
just going to press go
and then we're just going to let it do
his
thing and the slot will just be in the
cup
holder just like all of them will
be so after we got to this uh we can
just go ahead and hit continue right
here on the
bottom and we can go to the search
and we can
search
Pats and we can just hit
download after download we're just going
to hit
run and now we're going to put our nasta
credentials uh make sure in this uh you
must uh put that it's not going to let
you do without nasta so you can get into
the interface but to do make a keys and
to do anything related to the pads
you're going to need the nasta so I just
going to put it
in so we have placed the credentials and
uh it will be the the credential and the
Alti that you get the code and now we
just going to go and do program
keys and we're just going to take the
key and we're going to place it right
inside and we're just going to hit
select place the key to program so we
placed
it now it's programming the key and we
heard the two clicks so the number is
keys and the vehicle are
four and now we can see that the key is
programmed
obviously so the remote didn't work it
was definitely uh my fault um I didn't
know they had them in 433 frequency so I
made a mistake so now I just going to
generate the right one and I just going
to add the other key but you saw how
fast and how quick it is uh just doing
that so um I just going to make the
second one so the key that we had was
not the 900 frequency so we just
generated an outo key and we're just
going to put it there and do progr key
uh once again so again you just press
okay um and because uh the system was
shut off uh we just going to need to do
it
again so we're just going to
thing
off so we're just going to go back and
we're going
to do run again and this is the reason
that we couldn't do it we're just going
to do our condensins again so I going to
be white with you with that so we have
placed the credentials
again and now we're going to
go program
keys and hit
select so so now we're going to need to
do two keys again so we're just going to
press
yes cuz four keys are maximum and we
reach the maximum so we're just going to
add the keys now one after another so
program
key and we heard the two clicks
so now we're going to add also the
customer key back to the
system so we go program
keys and hit
okay so now the other one uh clicked in
so we can hit okay and now unlock unlike
before we can see that this remote works
and this one works as well
so and again this is an outl key that we
generated um so now after we done
putting those keys we can just do
exit and again you've seen once again
how easy it was to do that so we will
try also to retrieve the code of the
door while we here so if we're just
going to press code it says factory
keyless
entry so we're just going to press
download and then we're just going to
hit run
retrieve the display the factory code so
we just going to hit
continue and we're just going to hit
continue and the ignition is
on and we're just going to try it again
so we closed the door maybe it's was the
problems that the door was open so we're
just going to run it
again and we're just going to hit
okay continue I
mean so the door closed which we didn't
do
before and the ignition and on
and as you can see they're giving us the
code so if you guys ever need to find a
code this is how you would do it uh very
nice and easy so you can also do that
while you already have the fdrs open
when you open up the
fdrs um also if you want to download
that and do everything is going to be uh
the easiest way is just go to Google and
search for
fdrs
login and then this is going to
be the website you want to go on to so
here it's going to show you everything
and here it's going to show you how much
it is and just create a new
customer uh open account or if you're
existing just use existing customer um
but after you have done on that um
please make sure that you log in first
on here because when you're going to go
here you're going to choose
independent um and non dealer and then
you're going to hit login this is when
after you downloaded the software and if
you log in here and it keeps giving you
an error over here and saying
unidentify so just if you scroll down
all the way
here
um it's going to show you that you
should go to their website so basically
opening this website but not from the
fdrs just go and launch it on the on the
Google and do log in over there and then
it's going to ask you if you're locksm
or what are you um and this is the way
you can uh solve the problem if you're
having issues to connect so just make
sure that you are using this option log
in and then doing that um and for the
downloading website we're going to use
this uh website this is the the one that
you want to look for uh good luck for
you guys uh thank you guys for watching
and see you on the next video